i feel like we talk about the eagles way
more than we should given the quality of
the team right now but here's harry
roseman talking about jalen hurts and
their desire to see jalen hurts become
the starting quarterback this year play
the tape please
you're judging him off before nfl starts
in a tough situation with all the
interest injuries that we have you know
we want to see him grab the job and and
kind of run with it and see what you do
over a period of time and i remember you
told me this a long time ago you know
the the best body work the more you can
see a player play the more you can make
decisions on that player and i remember
we talked about this when we were
talking about you know even extending
players early versus getting the full
body of work and i think i think that
applies here to jalen you know we want
to be in a situation where we get as
much information as possible give him
the best opportunity you know build that
offensive line give him the right
weapons put him in a system that really
maximizes his ability and then go from
there
this is kind of like the gardner-minshew
attitude from last year i was a firm
believer the jaguars should keep the
coach the gm in place and give gardner
minshew a year one year to show that he
can be the guy if he is great if he's
not you move on to another one i kind of
think that's what the eagles are doing
here jalen hurts gets one year one year
given what drafting jalen hurts did
to the relationship between the eagles
and carson wentz give him a year as the
guy see what he can do and if he's good
enough you keep him if he's not you
continue your quest for a franchise
quarterback especially because i you
know this this
trend of disgruntled quarterbacks being
available in trade i don't think it's
going to end anytime soon i think as
time goes by there's going to be more
and more and more of these quarterbacks
who are with the team where they're not
satisfied with how it's going and
they're going to try to force their way
out to somewhere else
well sure and why not if it
if it works for a couple of them or
maybe even just one of them then that's
going to be able to open the door i
think for a lot of other guys in order
to do it when they're still under
contract i mean tom brady obviously is
one where he was not under contract any
longer and was able to sign with tampa
bay but look i think from the
conversations we've had about russell
wilson aaron rodgers deshawn watson
before all these cases came up against
him this off season i think there's
reason to believe that yes if a
quarterback gets disgruntled while he's
still under contract then he could
become available but also mike i mean
you're talking about the eagles they
have an extra first round pick next year
from miami from that trade where they
moved back uh into the top ten miami
moved back into the top ten i should say
so there should be some opportunity next
year for them to either trade up if they
want to use that asset that they have
from miami or they could still stay put
if jalen hurts turns out to be the guy
that they can trust at quarterback it
looks like you know they're putting
stuff around him right we'll see how
jalen rigor is in his second year there
if he can stay healthy and devante smith
look he won the heisman trophy he's a
really good player i think he should
still be in the nfl so there's gonna be
opportunity for jalen hurts to show that
he can be the guy in philadelphia but i
think you're right it's one here and if
you're not showing enough traits that
you can be that franchise qb then we're
out
and you know that's where the giants are
currently with daniel jones they want
him to show that he can ascend or they
quite likely will move on there are no
excuses right now for daniel jones after
what they've done to improve the weapons
around him so we're going to see
more and more teams applying pressure
more and more quickly to young
quarterbacks so they can get a feel for
whether or not that's the guy because
there's going to be plenty of other guys
out there and i think that that
carousel every year is going to spin
with options at the quarterback position
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports